brought to you by the PlayStation
experience in Las Vegas take part in all
the announcements panels and early game
previews December 6th and 7th hello and
welcome to in two minutes the show
that's evolving faster than an Evie
diving into a tub of fire stones this
week I thought I'd go for something a
little different series recaps of fun
and all but after weeks of locking
myself up in a darkened room like
Gandalf when he goes to the archives of
ministereth well it started to take its
toll so while I was busy adventuring and
saving the world in Dragon Age
Inquisition pagan min and his fabulous
suit burst out of kyrat and brought all
manner of explosive weapons wingsuit and
exotic animals with him I respect that
I've dragged in two of my favorite work
jumps Seb Ford and cam Robinson to
conduct some science kind of we just
messed around in Far Cry 4 snap editor
we all have the same weapons were at the
same location there's an elephant we
named Jeremy and it's been edited to
make us all look bad ass we're gonna see
if it's possible to smush an outpost
kill like 25 guys and try not to die in
just under two minutes so let's create
some chaos in kyrat role bTW I'm bloody
old for this game I didn't want to say
anything go go elephants oh no no I made
the mess oh god this is awful go after
white I don't like losing
all right one go down its OC dudes
they're very into the middle is that bad
thank you
I too like to live dangerously um huh
where are people to kill
okay this is my exploding down hey
friends that was good
okay four four nine you're doing good
you're doing good okay
come on I want an elephant what's the
point of being an elephant because it'll
squash everything I'm all right ladies
okay okay I've upset them now
I've definitely up so yeah okay do
although all right I'm going to use my
RPG now it stands for
rocket-propelled grenade le horse one of
they calls
that's 1100 I'm gonna go oh I'm really
gonna die there's so much [ __ ] mucho
hyperbolic power Kerala can mean it
you think Jeremy's pick up your scratch
I feel I feel like we're in tune it's
like Aragon do you I do read the books
watch that movie read moving to good
okay okay I'm really bad but on the plus
side no fourteen of them all right route
guys dead got a risk are down I lost you
billet kills seventeen no this is not
going so that's already doing it I just
making sure good you get good nine
seconds come on P she's not be setting
it on that barrel corrected mistake he's
okay
lesson learned hey where are you 23
that's alright look at that so it turns
out that elephants Plus RPGs plus big
red barrels equals explosions and death
and in one sense case victory cam sucks
if you'd like to beat us at our own game
we've uploaded the map we used so search
for Jeremy the elephant on far cry falls
map selector thing or if you want to
check out the original map download
elephant theory by Ubisoft be sure to
tweet me at least see James games with
your best times or some other cool maps
that we should check out here on the
show next week I'm heading back into
Bungie shared world shooter destiny try
and get my head around the plot before
the dark below dlc drops so I'll see you
next time
you